okay it is a much anticipated and also
much despised moment of the week
yes hatred mail is as much despised as
it is loved for different reasons the
hey tree it's dislike it for different
reasons than the left the leftist finds
it hugely depressing hugely hugely
depressing that these are the folks that
we are up against but what is hatred
mail
this is Hadrian male teachers can buy
their own school supplies but will throw
in the Glock for free Patriot man
written by Patriots who hate David
Pakman because America and because
freedom okay this week's hatred mail
addresses my commentary on economic
systems socialism social democracy
capitalism the the winnings and failings
are the shortcomings and advantages of
different act what am I talking about
they just mentioned the word socialism
and call me a [ __ ] take a listen to this
David may be zero percent socialist like
he says but a 100 percent a cook whoa
David Pakman I almost forgot you were a
shill for a second there's nothing wrong
with segregation David stop being a
degenerate sympathizing cuck I really
can't believe that the left even allows
people like these weaklings soy boys to
be spokespeople how did I even get past
the gatekeeping of the left such that I
have become a spokesperson for it that
would really be the amazing thing I
think you got the percentages wrong -
yeah like I think it's 10% cuck 20%
shill fifteen percent concentrated power
of oil something like that yeah and then
the rest of Social Democrat yes and then
that's it that's how I would I just
think that it's inaccurate more than it
is offensive if you want to upset the
hatred if you want to send a middle
finger to these people who are trying to
pull down what we hold so dear is the
fundamental tenets of the United States
of America use the coupon code hatred
for tea when you sign up for membership
at WWJ pakman.com when you do that and
use that coupon code hey tree at 40
you'll say 40%
and 67 hatreds will cry which is a bit
fewer than last week but still a pretty
solid number